Wasn't Destiny mocking children that drown in the Texas blood?
Yes, he is trying to find more psychopaths for his audience.
So, he will tweet psychopathic things because he is a psychopath.
I'm so glad that I just kept highlighting how insecure he is
and why he's going to cover this. And then he just he literally
couldn't stop himself. Despite me saying it multiple times, he
still has to go and do all of this. Point out that um there is
somebody who you should all watch if you're a DJer and you're
here, okay? There is somebody you should watch. All right? And
this is mostly based on I I realized this the other day and I
had to point it out. Okay, Destiny's patchy, disgusting, balding
beard. Okay, I noticed that there's
there's basically somebody who uh who has like a painted on beard.
Look at how full this beard is.
I'm like, I didn't prepare a lot in my docket today. Let me just
scan really quickly. See what he was covering.
Next level leeching. Let me just see what he was covering. I'll
go see maybe some interesting. I've got all the Dan stuff. I
think I'm going back and forth on whether I'm going to do some
uh some Destiny stuff here cuz I think um I'll He's going to
be so mad. Do we have a Do we have like a time stamp or something?
Is there like a Hold on. I mean, I can I can see where in the
VOD he starts, but yeah, he does I'll just go check his actual
thing. We'll see what's up. Yeah, he does kind of yell for about
an hour or so.
we could just honestly just start. Well, I don't know how because
I haven't watched it yet either. So, I guess we can just find
out together. If any of it's boring, we could just speed through
it. Oh, I just realized I also Oh. Oh, there's like a You want
to do the dance stuff first? No, no, no, no, no. But there is
a bunch of good stuff here. Also,
I just realized I stream like five hours after him in the day.
I can just go I can just go like steal his like anything he's
doing for drama stuff. I could just go steal those. I've got
a whole sheet telling me what he's coming. I This is like a perfect
resource. I just didn't realize it. I'm I'm looking at this sheet
right here. It's like, oh, um he's like talking about Dorio or
something somewhere around here. It's like, oh, I'll just snipe
those. Let's go. Not his coverage, just whatever he is covering.
I can just go uh I just go take those. Let's go. I'm always looking
for like good places to go collection.
But I don't see as a transitional mental who thinks he's a noble
gas. Sorry, what did you just say? Or are we going to say I don't
know.
Oh, do we not have time stamps for today? Wait, is it No, it's
the 7th today. Oh, I'm on the wrong month, aren't I? No, I'm
not. Wait, what the Why don't I have There is no No, there are
no time stamps for today. God damn it.
Nope. No time stamps. Somebody else got to go get the time stamps
for today.
Should watch this before anything else. Well, I have the time
of when he
I have the time stamp of when he starts talking today. Okay.
So, the only thing I would And also because I said she's getting
fat, which she is. You can tell by the way she positions her
camera. Now, she's gone back to having a live camera on all of
her streams to try to prove that she's not fat. I think
uh I I won't say anything about like what's up, but I think you
were out one of these days and then the other day you were just
like
Yeah, the other day you were
like it's basically like done a bunch of stuff in that day. Yeah.
When a I don't know how to copy a video at a certain euro a certain
time stamp if the video
Yeah. But literally, if you just
if you just scan through the video, you'll see when as soon as
he opens your VOD, it's like um just Yeah, just tell me just
link me the VOD and then um all you got to do is link me the
VOD and then just say my whatever time you're at.
Go to his live stream. Just write right click and send it to
me. I don't uh
Hang on then. No, it's fine, Kelly. It's fine.
4.9K. Why is he getting mobbed by Nicholas Dioro so badly? What
the Oh, he just he just ended. It's right here. You're right.
You're right. You're right. Every superhero movie is always bad
Yeah, it's about who I guess has a degree in me molecular biology
showed up and he's like I don't know why you're saying this,
Kelly. I don't think you're necessarily correct here. And she's
been like soy freaking the out over. It's not what he said. So
the guy Yeah. Sorry. you want to speak or I was just going to
say apparently Destiny just read a bunch of vlogs for my Discord
today which I think is uh I think it's hilarious and he just
pushes more people into the Discord
and as more DJers enter the Discord, okay, as more DJers enter
the Discord, we get more people to make fun of. We get more people
to be like, "Hey, why don't you come on and explain to us how
you have like no basis for any of your thoughts?" It's so fun
every time.
So realistically, please just keep feeding me your poor
brainwashed cult members and we'll keep chewing through them.
It's very fun. It's just great. To be fair, this mind's guy wasn't
being like a cultist to me. He was just uh he just refused to
look at the although I am also talking about minds to some extent.
He's not as bad as other Well, then don't interrupt me. Let me
finish the sentence.
Um,
so like he just refused to kind of take the context of what Destiny
was talking about because when I try to say for like the third
time, so that's why the context is important. He then admits
that he doesn't think what Destiny said is right. It's just that
he wanted to make his point, which was not contrary to anything
I was saying. So I was just kind of like
that seemed like a waste of time. It's like he was just explaining
to me something that I had already explained earlier in the chat,
which is that I know the difference between reactivity
and chemical reactivity and what stability is. And for some reason,
he decided to explain that concept again to me after I'd already
done it. So, it was like, yes, I'm aware.
The context is Destiny saying a bunch of stupid on his stream.
You still there?
Yeah, I listen to all of that. I sorry I went and I started making
a drink because it was like chemistry stuff. Uh so it sounds
like that's kind of funny because he did that same thing last
night with us where instead of actually arguing that we were
wrong on anything, he like started trying to invent a hypothetical
where he could just make a nothing point that didn't apply to
the current situation. And it's like why do you feel the need
to like try to argue in favor of somebody while not even correcting
the people you're arguing with while just trying to create a
world where you can still maintain your cope? I don't I don't
understand it pretty much. Yeah, I just don't get it. Uh I Hold
on. I didn't walk off and like stop listening to her. I listened
to the whole thing and responded accordingly. I just went to
go get some caffeine cuz I was like, "Oh,
Kelly's talking." I wasn't actually talking about anything chemistry
related. I was just saying what Mines had said didn't contradict
anything I had said. It's just simply he wanted to make the point
that from a chemistry perspective you can use the word unstable
to mean something that's chemically reactive. And whilst you
can do that if in the context of what you're talking about doesn't
also reference something that is chemically reactive as well
as unstable like you're trying to make the point that something
is X and then something is Y and then using the same word for
both. It obviously makes no sense. Um, but then he he admits
he says, "I'm not defending what Destiny said. I'm just saying
you're just as
So, I'm sure that message from Mines will not be included in
this im. But I guess we'll see.
We'll see. We'll see. Only thing I would expect here, there's
no way Destiny would spend time trying to prove that he was correct
over Kelly, right? There's no way his ego is fragile enough that
he'd have to go and prove that he was correct and Kelly include
this. I think when she's thinking sodium, she's thinking like
um do do you think she's thinking of like table salt? He doesn't
even think of something. I'm not figure it out himself. Yeah,
I said fluoride and not sodium as well, but I mean what is happening
the same fluoride isn't in the periodic table. He means florine.
He does this several times for some reason. Oh well, we love
a panic queen, Kelly. Thank you. I also one of my favorite things
happens here, too. I just like to Wait, that was past you, wasn't
it? Not present. Yeah, that was past me. That was past me. I
don't know how we're going to do this. I got to pull up I got
to pull up like the what do you call it? The preview window and
make it big so I can see when you're actually talking. Yeah,
I'll do the same thing. You got baited last time. I got baited
this time.
I was agreeing with you from the past.
People like Cherry or Kelly, Jessica would fight with him like
crazy, but he has to do this thing where he has to like rain.
I explicitly say, "I'm not going to fight with you on anything
here. I don't care about chemistry, but you come on my stream
all the time. Thank you for coming on my stream. You want to
talk about this? You, you know, you wrote some notes?" Yeah.
Go talk about it for a little bit. Go like explain what your
point is and and why he's Yeah, that's explicitly what I said.
What does he mean I have to fight? I just said I don't care.
Yeah. I asked before the stream started, "Hey, could we do like
a little bit of this?" And he said yes. I just said it's actually
just for my own fun. It's not for anything.
It's just funny. It's literally just like, yeah, Kelly comes
on stream all the time, talks about watches stuff that like I
I care about and she doesn't necessarily. It's like, oh, she
can do this for a little bit. She can talk for a little bit about
this. Why not? Kelly gets a little bit of science as a treat.
And also, we get to bully Destiny at the same time. So, it's
always good.
to give them free reign because they're there just to me. One
of those moments is happening right now. So, he makes the joke
that she's being pedantic.
I don't think I've ever
he just said that with Chelly. Chelly. Chelly. Carrie. Chelly.
Carrie. Chelly. I just did it twice. I just did it twice in a
row. Me. My brain's imploding. Uh, Kelly and Cherry. I don't
think Cher's ever come on and like talked to him. I think Cherry
mostly just, you know, if he's a topic talk about him at all.
Probably gets similarly disgusted. So
What do you call this? Wait, like do you call them columns?
They just put an element in the water. That's crazy. Do you call
these columns
a good start? Oh, wait. Is it Wait, is it not here? They have
an argument for
I'm so glad that I mixed in explaining why he is like an insecure
while like while this ran so that they had to listen to it, right?
I'm so glad. I was like, wait, how am I going to keep viewers
during this thing? And I'm like, oh, I'll just keep explaining
like why this is funny because this just Destiny off. because
he'll get so mad that Kelly's correcting him on something that
he will feel he'll feel like he has to go correct it. It won't
be like, oh, you know, I don't like this person. I don't want
them in my community. I don't want to be around them. It won't
be like that. It'll just be he'll just get like he'll just see
and have to I have to try to correct.
Dude,
they go back and forth for like two minutes on whether or not
it's pedantic. Maybe it's coming in the That's funny.
that's a funny bit.
Oh, but also Florian is not in the same group.
No, it's not in the same group. It's just simply in the periodic
table. He said fluoride.
Yeah. So, but even if you meant Florine, so he pre-watched. Yeah,
he probably watched it live to tell you the truth. He loves this
stream. He watches a lot of it. Okay. He takes a lot of it in.
I think he has to be honest. He just likes beefing with me. I
think he gets enjoyment from it. He always has done in the past.
He just needs to own it and be like, I like beefing with Kelly.
It's funny, but he'll never admit it. I didn't say it about uh
like
sodium. I said it about florine or Yeah, he mentions
florine
and says uh this is my side, I think. Well, he kind of floats
over Neon and Florine. So, I don't know. What level of hate watching
is I don't know. Especially right after is like, "Yeah, I don't
know about chemistry." And he's like, and he says florine instead
of fluoride. He mixes it up. I said that, not just I don't think
I said that, did I? It was me.
Okay. I just said they're putting an element in the water. That's
crazy, chat. Like I am literally doing the most surface level
nothing.
Wait, did he flo There's no way he moused over Francium.
You do pick up. You really
There's a central point that I want to bring this up at the end
of this like five minutes that kind of ties in other stuff I
talked about before. It's the funniest part of this whole thing
to me. We'll see if anybody gets
is he like he because he's going to argue that things in this
group like I was arguing about florine but it's the same group
or whatever, right? It's not Well, he said fluoride, but he clearly
didn't fluoride because he was trying to correct on compound
anyway, right? So, but then he went down. He was like, "Where's
this that I was talking about?"
That's not how it works. Yeah.
Oh, ping again.
Directly into the microphone. when he's taking so long.
Destiny calling you. His number one antivan is just projecting
at this point.
I
this is, you know, I'm not even better at this point. Honestly,
it just annoys him when I watch for some reason.
So, like I I ser I don't even really want to watch. I I know
that there are way better things to spend my time on. Although,
today I didn't prepare much. So, today he got lucky. Okay. We
just didn't we didn't have all that much else going on. So, we
get to spend some time watching this. She said that to her
between unstable and radioactive.
No, there isn't. I said unstable and So, this whole thing started
because I mentioned something about I think it was sodium being
like highly um I think I said like volatile and unstable.
And I don't know if when that Chernobyl
series came out, she decided to read something about
like stability of nuclear or something. And she and so in her
mind she's like, "Oh my god, he said
Uh, reminder, Destiny's entire interest in anything medical comes
from House MD. But that has to do with radction.
This is the height of projection. I said I responded to that
clip in real time. Like um,
when you played it originally on your stream, I was spamming
in the chat because no one else was saying it. And I said, "The
only unstable sodium in Destiny's life is the amount that he
eats on a daily basis, right?"
So, he's kind of suggesting that I for some reason researched
it at a later point. I'm like, I don't know what he thought about,
but okay. Radioactive decay and not reactivity for a particular
thing. And I and I so she goes on this whole thing of
and he doesn't know what that unstable is radioactive.
But it's so funny because and I'll explain at the end of this.
Um, by the way, my chemistry sucks. So I like how they're like,
"Oh, he's got such a huge ego." But there are some things I He's
speaking.
Why is he Yeah, he just Did he not listen to the original point?
Cuz your chat heard the original point, which was, hey, you don't
know anything about chemistry. Just admit that. Move forward.
And like you don't have to correct Kelly or anything. You just
like you're just like, "Oh, I don't know anything about chemistry.
If I misspoke, I misspoke." You know how hard you win if you
do that? If you just go, "Oh, I misspoke." And other people get
mad about it.
Just go, "Oh, I misspoke." His chemistry sucks. Still better
than Kelly. Omfg. He's pro. I can't believe that you care. I
can't believe that you care. It's actually more embarrassing
for you to care than Destiny. Only slightly, but it's still actually
more conceptually about chemistry. Imagine filling the need to
like desperately like argue a point with a cosplayer.
It's like he seems to have this idea that I care about being
seen as smart when it's not a benefit to me at all. Like I would
make more money and do better by just being a bimbo. Like it
doesn't benefit me in any way. And also knowing like high school
chemistry doesn't make you smart. That's what everyone should
know. This is stuff everyone should know.
Nothing
I'm talking about here. And if Yes, you should, too. I'm going
to make everyone know exactly what I'm talking about, but she
doesn't. So, it's just very funny watching them go through
And he doesn't understand how those two things are connected.
They are the same thing. Uh, be very vivic. Everybody pretend
or sorry, everybody cares about being perceived as like smart
and correct. Like people, nobody wants to be perceived as a except
maybe if you're trying to make money on the internet. Okay. But
like nobody really wants to Everybody wants some level of like,
hey, I care about this. I'm correct. We don't have to I don't
So he's further I don't really care. No, I don't care about being
seen as smart. I don't obviously like it when people assume that
I'm stupid, but there's a difference between that and like thinking
that I have an intelligence that is beyond like exceptional.
Like I don't that is dumb. I think it's it's annoying when people
are dismissive of the stuff you say and just yell at you that
you're 10 times in a row, but like I don't care about being seen
as smart. My ears are burning. You just don't want to be dismissed,
right? Yeah, I was a little bit showing he's further showing
his ignorance here, guys. Wow. Groups are columns that are more
radioactive on the periodic table. Maybe there are, but I've
never heard that before. Or I mean, it might be true. I just
I don't know anything about that. Reread it. Read it again. You
got to be going to learn. Okay. You don't want to be the her
God. I got to speed this up a little I can't believe we're rerunning
this segment a second day. We're We're actually going to watch
this entire segment back a second time. You guys should demand
better. You You chatters here right now should demand better.
And reactive.
Oh, I mean I guess maybe like unstable might imply radioactive.
Yes, unstable is radioactive.
Reactive is two things combining.
Two very different terms in chemistry. The bottom side mean similar
things. Oh, isn't everything in that column? Hold on. What does
he I'll read the Obviously a Google Scholar this, but I'm sure
we find at least one paper where somebody refers to something
in the um in that leftmost group as being unstable and like volatile
and reactive. There are three different words. Of course, it
can be some of them.
I I just don't understand how that would how would that be like
how would that prove anything? I don't Yeah, I'm sure somebody
made a mistake somewhere that made it through review. I'm sure
somebody did somewhere,
dude. I
How How is he this insecure? I don't understand. I literally
don't get it.
Yeah,
I dude. And it's obviously not talking about the stability in
terms of radioactive decay, but which element on the table is
the most electrogative? I think it's I think it's I think it's
florine, which is why I thought it was in that leftmost group.
I guess if if you're unaware. Um yeah. Okay. So that was the
mistake. I was just like dude like come on. Like it's funny that
you up the groups. Okay. He already has admitted his base mistake.
I don't know why he's going to go after Kelly and read through
all these Discord logs and they they don't ever pick up on this
because I don't know again I don't know if they just wiki certain
things but like my all of my understanding the only understanding
I have left of I learned this in high school like a decade ago
and I don't care. What do you mean my understand? My understanding
is just remembering stuff from high school chemistry. That's
it. Well, I technically took university chemistry. I technically
took organic chem. I got like the worst mark in my entire university
career. And organic chem. Okay. I don't know anything about it.
Uh chemistry was just whatever I again I say like I memorize
things. Like if I have a conceptual foundation to it, then I
can kind of remember some things. But if I'm just like memorizing
discreetly, I can't I don't I won't remember things discreetly.
But it's Oh, I knew he'd talk about like learning and how he's
just trying to learn. No, it wasn't that you were trying to learn.
It's that you're like it's that you were seething and correcting
Kelly. It's that you were mad, right? Like that's not Nobody
has a problem with you trying to learn. Why are you getting a
beef with Kelly Jean? It's funny because like if you have any
idea she called you dumb. Deal with it. Just move on. Yeah. How
this works then I feel like you would pretty easily understand
like why am I looking for Florine over here and why am I talking
about these things being unstable? The more correct word might
be reactive. I I guess it was reactive. Um, yes, but the uh the
period table elements you honestly I just want to close the stream
right there and be like, "Okay, he just admitted he's wrong."
He like admitted he's wrong. Okay, admitted he's wrong. And then
he's just going to pull up these logs because somebody who actually
knows what they're talking about argued with Kelly and he's like,
"Well, Kelly's not that smart either, guys. He He hasn't even
He's actually given up on the idea of proving that he knows more
than Kelly already and he's going now he's falling back to like,
well, somebody knows more than Kelly." Yeah, I'm pretty sure
that's true for every topic on planet Earth. Okay. Yes, there
are a lot of people that know more than me. Jesus Christ.
You can infer a lot of um a lot of uh would you say chemical
properties? You can infer a lot of properties uh for how these
things interact with each other because this is laid out in a
way that has to do with um a lot of the um like properties of
the of the element itself. So, I'm pretty sure everything here
on the left So, why did you get it so wrong?
all of it wrong. How did you get all of it wrong? It's because
he's since gone and looked it up. He's like, "These people must
have just used Wikipedia."
But that's literally, Hold on. That's literally the point when
I say that um that sodium
and uh and florine aren't in the same group. Like, I thought
that was his whole point of saying they were the same thing.
Like, that was the whole point of them both being brought up.
No. And I was like, "Oh, they're not even in the same group.
I can't believe he thought that." And he admitted that he thought
they were in the same group. And now he's like explaining what
the groups mean and why it's important as if we didn't know that.
No, that was literally the only point I made in this entire thing
Um, in in uh in all of your you have your nucleus and you got
like little electrons that go around your electron clouds, I
think is what they call them or no orbits. There were letters
for these, but I don't remember them. Is it two a Okay, I'm not
I'm not sitting here listening to him explain veilance and stuff.
I'm not doing
with the helium
painful
ionic bonds. I don't know what that has to do with Ionic bonds
aren't considered to be a molecule. Fluoride bonds metallic bond.
Oh, can fluoride exist on its own as an ion as a single? Oh,
maybe it might be able to like aside from chemistry. Fluoride
is the ion.
Definitely if it's in water on compound bonds,
but coalent bonds usually are. So, like all you have to do here
is say, by the way, just so you guys know, okay, all you have
to do here is say, oh yeah, I don't know anything about chemistry
is probably wrong, right? That's all you got to do, but because
it's Kelly who said it, he's got to get into the stream segment
and Kelly just likes to highlight that. Okay, so her name is
Destiny is fat. Yeah, because I Well, we found out now that apparently
Jessica was feeling really bad about his weight when Kelly coached
him like four months ago. I'm so glad to go to the gym and stuff
and see. I'm so so so glad that uh
I'm so glad that I just kept highlighting how insecure he is
and why he's going to cover this and then he just he literally
couldn't stop himself despite me saying it multiple times. He
still has to go and do all of this is fantastic. I think that's
when Kelly started to attack me for being fat. I guess want you
guys to remember what we're That is the entire reason. I think
she just started calling you fat and kept calling you fat for
like ever. I don't even know when it when it necessarily started.
I actually don't The only reason why we're doing this is because
he's bothered by it, right? I I would not be doing this otherwise.
But the fact that he spoke about this three times and also in
four times now, I like how the admission is that she's going
to come on and hijack like 40 minutes of his content just because
of how mad it makes me. And well, it's not hijack.
preemptively asked I asked uh where the stream started.
Yeah. And I Yeah. been literally debating in their Discord server
like for days
about this subject
in the Discord.
Load 87 more images. Oh no. I look forward to him accusing me
of scamming the government again. I don't know why he makes me
so powerful.
Oh my god.
The more credit than he deserves cuz he is a doughy bolding fatso.
I like how they have to make a carve out though for the women
that I've serve because then on them obviously. So they have
to like Oh, but like Oh, no. Zoe, she's like really pretty though.
It's just like So wait, is there a rule against calling Zoe ugly
or something?
What are we crazy? Um, why is he reading this out? Is he this
guy himself on carpet cleaning chemicals? It's funny, actually.
I don't think he's banned from the Discord. If you want, you
can just join the Discord, Destiny. You can just join and read
this live if you want. I'm fine with that.
Like I I don't have to ban this guy. He could just come and sit
in the discord. The unhingedness. Girl, I think you sound smart
as you sound like you have a brain. I would love to pick just
because of the fascinating.
This is Hannah, the girl that try to trap me into saying some
discord who's filled out an affidavit against me.
He's got a seed about every girl
on the daily basis. That's uh brilliant. Like Hannah, Zoe,
Shel, they all live in his head rentree. It's so cool. I don't
I just think it's hilarious that he
is this big a fan. He'd just come join. He'd just be there.
And then I love saying this. How do you not at least remember
unstable elements are mostly the man-made elements at the later
end of the table that quickly break down or that an element being
unstable means it's radioact? Like it's such a weirdly bizarre
thing to say that if somebody were to say, "Oh, I think sodium
is kind of unstable." Like if your mind instantly were to go
to Why is that a bizarre thing to say? Why would that be a bizarre
thing to think? You're looking at the periodic table. Why would
that be an odd thing to not think of? What?
Why is I think he's saying, "Why didn't you give him charity,
Kelly? Why didn't you give this guy charity? You knew. You could
have pointed him the right direction. Why didn't you Why didn't
you give him charity?"
Because he's an idiot. Why does this millionaire care about uh
Listen, that's a weird thing to say. A far weirder thing to do
in general is to be a millionaire who could do whatever they
want. You live in one of the nicest cities on planet Earth. You
go out on the water. You do whatever the you want with your life,
right? And you're going to sit here and read Discord logs from
Kelly Jean. That's what you've decided to do with your life.
That's I'm sorry. Nobody else reads everything Kelly says like
Destiny does. That's the funny thing. Other people are like,
"Kelly,
Kelly, you know what? It's too much." Destiny's like, "No, I
need more Kelly Jean in my life." Every I don't know what it's
called. Isn't that going to get wrinkles from laughing so much?
just like
I never laughed so much in the last few days. And you reveal
him doing it. As I said, a past eight. Okay. As I said, I literally
didn't prepare anything for the stream today. Okay. I'm like
winging it beyond the Dan Dioro stuff which I actually followed.
Okay. I prepared basically nothing and I just I was just like,
you know what? I'll show up. Uh we'll we'll see what happens.
And this happened. So this is what we're doing Talking about
it gives away. It does. No, that does make me smile. The idea
that he would have had to have someone or he did go through like
logs of locker posting in my Discord just to get to these messages.
I don't know if any of the
I'm not going to remember. It's like the first hundred uh elements
I think or Can you pause for a sec? Wait, isn't it 92?
What are the weird comments in the chat? When have I joked about
Oh, I have no idea. Isn't it just 90
approaching 45th birthday that you can feel creeper dude's here
around time been here a long time I would not ban him but for
people who just joined recently Sophia who just want to like
say random I don't know what that guy that guy was just annoying
from earlier but you could just perma it's fine don't give them
a weak ban and then they come back make them make a new account
I was just curious are we getting like the DGG
no the creeper dude the creeper dude guy just doesn't like you
the creeper dude guy's been here a long
What's his name? Creeper. Did you say Creeper dude? 2006. I recognize
that guy. He's been here a long time. Yeah. Oh, okay. Fair enough.
Somebody said, "Oh, why would Kelly joke about Reckful committed?"
It's like, um, because I wouldn't let one a bad event in my life
prevent me from like doing humor around a topic. Probably. I
would imagine. Anyway, back to this. What was I joking about?
Anyway, is it like the thing where I said about how did he knock
himself in car leaning?
I'm so confused. I have no idea. For the That would be death
by stupidity. But the Darwin award. Yeah. Elements. We technically
we can like create an element by just shoving more and more um
protons I think into a thing, but they're obviously they're super
unstable and need decay in like
micros secondsonds or something. So they're not like I don't
even know if you'd say they're real elements. They're not elements
that are What is he talking about?
Wait, is he talking about Oh, okay. Like man-made synthetic.
Okay.
It's not exactly the process of Oh, nice. I didn't notice this.
I hope he never gets a fake disease that affects his memory.
Wasn't Destiny mocking children that drown in the Texas flood?
Yes, he is trying to find more psychopaths for his audience so
he will tweet psychopathic things because he is a psychopath.
I don't know. I try not to draw attention to the the [__]
vampire rake bait. It's just like too much, you know? Like it's
just it's actually so boring at this point. Like he just keeps
laughing at dead kids to try to get somebody to pay attention
to him, right?
Isn't anybody paying attention to me yet? I'm laughing at dead
kids. Why aren't you paying attention to me? Like you're weird.
You're a weirdo. You're just a weirdo. At any point that would
be bad. I'm just trying to like I would let him know that suppress
the urge to continue to keep correcting him, but like I feel
like this might never end if I keep doing it.
can be caused can be caused by a gain of function mutation in
the SCN9A gene. But unfortunately he thinks it's a fake disease
I just made up. Destiny trying to learn about gain of function
when he doesn't have a basic understanding of anything is quite
funny. But if I didn't know anything about chemistry bring table
and gesture wildly and say X elements are unstable or volatile
when they are not. Oh no, this is so funny.
She uses chat GPT for reasoning. Yeah, I remember when she posted
that on on uh except I've just my my message there is saying
that Googlei doesn't know how to differentiate, but okay. Uh
OMFG, he's pro you you're coming up later. Okay, you kind of
Discord or maybe he's always going to be in the dance segment.
I never said sodium wasn't unstable, but stability and reactivity
go hand in hand. If chemical is unstable, more often than not,
it's very reactive. Stability of a molecule can drive.
I don't even know if that's true. I don't know. enough about.
And so Kelly starts arguing with this guy. I thought Mines had
a molecular biology degree or something. Did he come in and like
totally it up? Mines is a DG. Yeah, Mines has been on the stream
multiple times. Hold on one second. Uh Mines has been on the
stream multiple times. He's the guy who comes in, knows nothing,
gets totally educated, gets everything wrong, totally conceded
on every single point, and then comes back like two weeks later
and tries to argue again. And it's uh it's very very very funny
how he constantly resets. You're not debating him on my stream
about chemistry. You guys want Okay, but no, I don't want to
do that. I just want to do a clarifying quick statement to it.
He tried to say that there's a correlation between unstable as
in radioactive and un like and reactive as in reacts with things.
There is no correlation between those two things. If he didn't
mean that, then I don't know what he's saying.
So, wait, somebody said important minds lore, but what is it?
What is this?
Uh was arguing with Kelly about this.
stable and unstable have drastically different meanings in the
field of chemistry based on the context.
It was me chat. I cooked her out good bro. Kelly is so stupid
especially about chemistry. I got on her skin so hard. Destiny
extreme agreements disagreements. Move me out king. Oh, he really
wanted to get on stream with
That's why even though he said I don't agree with what Destiny
said by the end of it. Interesting. H
I think Man of the Minds knows that what Destiny said in his
original clip was kind of dumb. They just wanted to try and pick
at me for some reason now
to get on his stream, I guess. I don't uh hold on. PJ Forehead.
Yeah, you missed uh you missed some some uh growth. Okay. Uh
hold on. Let me load up my election night stream thing. This
is my election night outfit. Look at it. Got a little Liberal
Party of Canada emblem on the top and everything. Yeah, I know.
We're very much in favor of the Liberals in this election. Just
so you know, if you actually care, I don't think you actually
care. So, have a good night. Bye-bye.
No, they don't. An element can have a stable isotope or an unstable
isotope and be reactive or unreactive. There is no correlation.
They affect nothing or they affect different parts of the atom.
That's why when you're gesturing like an idiot, it's so important
to specify what you mean, as conflation of these two concepts
leads to people saying stupid things. AI is also notoriously
bad because people won't be clear without language. Lol. Oh,
she's mad because she asked chat GBT earlier whether or not unstable
and reactive meant the same thing and it was like, "Yeah, you
can use these interchangeably." And so she's like, "Oh, AI."
Is he just making this up or did this
No. So AI, if you put it into like Google, it won't be able to
differentiate between the terms. So because they're quo used
like interchangeably, right? So a Google AI summary will not
be able to understand like and give you like a a proper response.
Chat GPT can because I tested
But um even then like there's no there's nothing wrong in using
unstable to mean chemically reactive if within the context of
the conversation you're having it a makes sense and b you're
not trying to use it to mean two different things. Cuz what he
does is he uses it
um to mean chemically reactive, but then also gestures at something
that like to say this thing is stable as in it isn't chemically
reactive. So it can't be it can't be used in the context that
he's using it cuz he's trying to Yeah, I don't know. He's either
wrong about one thing or wrong about the other thing. It's like
reliable here. Although when it came to my legal stuff, you got
to be clear with your language. Was very copy pasting chat GBT.
So but for this stuff it's fair. I did not use any chachi for
this earlier. There are different uses for the word stable. Sodium
is unstable and highly reactive partly because of how sodium's
veent orbital is unfilled.
It has one electron when a full no it cannot be okay quickly.
It cannot be unstable and highly reactive. It can simply be highly
reactive. And I can use the word unstable to mean highly reactive.
You can't say it's unstable and high highly reactive because
you're saying that these two different terms are two different
things. It can only mean that these two words mean the same thing
and I'm using it this way. It can't mean that they're two different
words and they're both of those things.
Okay. Uh 25 subs if we skip this segment. 25 subs if we skip
this segment. But Kelly is Oh, that's not fair. I have no idea.
I'm sorry.
I'm having fun. Unstable. Electron configur. Okay, sorry. Hold
on. Not 25. Uh 50 subs if we skip the segment. Okay.
If I make that much money, Kelly, we skip the segment. Okay.
And then wait, I want to go to bed then, I guess. Oh, [__]
I guess so many random screenshots. I don't think I have the
one. She tries to pull credentials on the guy or like ask him
like, "What even is your background or whatever?" And and I think
he said like, "I have a bachelor's in I don't think I did that."
He decided to tell about his background, but I didn't ask him
for it. I did not do that at all. So, he's just lying. Yes, he
does just Yeah, he just makes things up. He like so often does
this. It's I feel like he didn't do it before, but it's hard
to say. Did anyone do that to you, man of the minds, or did you
just decide to share your education background? But it wasn't
me that questioned your background,
huh? I was thinking about this earlier today, like why did I
like Destiny a like when I first started watching him? I think
I hit the worst possible timing where he started getting interested
in Lauren Southern and thought he had to be a good person to
to Lauren Southern and was trying to be a good person and then
I think he like basically I got like invested when he was like
faking like skinwalking being a like moral human being and then
and then I was like fooled and then he just went back to his
normal you totally
immoral totally degenerate self. Yeah. Unfortunate. Unlucky.
And then she just gets super out. Oh, wait, wait. It might be
on this album. Hold on. All message does is explain sodium is
high, which I didn't disagree with at any point.
Had a a science book. Jesse ruined Lauren Southern's reputation,
the rightwing. And he doxed her son to everybody, the whole world.
So based I just can't believe that they they spent so much time
talking about me. It's so unhinged.
Oh,
the mind's guy did not attend the science lesson yesterday.
I have a degree in biochemistry. I learned this Oh, so she literally
didn't question his credentials at all. He just offered it as
a He just offered it because she was like, "Oh, you don't know
what you're talking about." Okay, got it. Got it. No shot by
Element in the periodic table. Is it being gesture? I love the
idea that or sorry, the fact that he also read all of these first
before he went on stream and is so like ass pained about this
that he can't pretend he didn't, right? He's not even pretending
that he's reading this for the first time. This is his second
read through. No, that's never been true. Ezekiel Snake, why
would I get more emotional now than when originally went down?
Why would you get emotional about him being confused about science?
Also, this is like the least emotional subject to be going over,
It's just stupid. I think it's so funny that he um he read all
of this. He like goes over it with his chat. Okay. When he first
sends like the clip of Kelly talking about it, was it like the
day before or whatever when he called him dumb? He like sends
that twice in his chat. He talks through it with his chat. Then
he goes on stream and like talks about again.
And then when Kelly responds in Discord, he gets a massive album
of all her Discord messages, reads it once off stream to make
sure he understands how what he's supposed to argue, and then
he reads it again on his stream. He has messages from right before
you started streaming too.
He knows where some part Yeah, exactly. Be very vivic. Like he
is he is literally skipping over things he doesn't want to read,
right? That he doesn't want on stream and he is just going to
like specific things he's looking for. He's like, I think Kelly
like questioned this guy's credentials and then yeah, of course,
he gives his credentials and unstable and is not unstable because
it has at least one stable isotope and the idiot in question
actually meant reactive. Then yes, they are very wrong. I love
all of the they do this on my Q farms. They all do these like
weird exclamation mark things. They all type like um just Tical
talks. In this case, 100% is a compound accusing me of posting
on Kiwi Farms. Dude, I always
don't think I knew about Kiwi Farms before I was in Destiny's
community. I think I learned about it from Destiny's community.
Maybe Destiny himself during the Keep. I actually don't know.
But I always I always I do the the Trump speak, right? The like
oh many such cases. I do that all the time, right? That's like
the way I talk. That's the way I type. I don't know. I have a
completely stable form of naturally existing sodium. Lol. Calling
sodium unstable makes you very stupid.
I'm so confused. Did you ever claim to be an expert in chemistry?
No, not at all. This all stems from I think on stream I made
some comment about how I thought um I think I said something.
I thought sodium was was very re unstable and volatile. I said
something like that and then for some reason she felt the need
to like hone in on she like corrected you and then you felt the
need to go and like Google it and argue about why you were saying
what you were saying on stream and then you realized you were
totally wrong about everything you said on stream and now you're
here being like I just like learning guys and I don't know why
she was so pedantic with me and rude. It's so weird. It's so
weird,
dude. You
uh why why is why is he like on that statement a ton chat GBT
can actually understand the difference between unstable and reactive,
but Google AI can't? Lol. I tested it. I'll post it here. Give
me a couple minutes while I get my email. You simply losing on
the basis of not knowing the context, brother. I give up on this
one. Destiny couldn't see Florine on the periodic table with
the big F, so we had to Google it. The level of hate watching.
You're literally reacting to our clip where we do that. You're
literally reacting to the clip, but we don't we don't run through
before the stream. I don't run through before the stream. You
just streamed this. I literally I don't I think I was live while
you did this. I can't pre-watch. I literally just I'm watching
it once. I'm spending half as much time as you on this stuff.
Here, Stacia. Remember, these people are so afraid of me that
they won't be witnesses in the case, but they have no
A person has no problem saying DJs are hard-headed when the head
of DG leaked them. non-conensually. Really? You think that's
like a That's a crazy message right there. I don't know why he
keeps highlighting Stage. I I think he
I think he knows exactly what he's doing and why he consistently
highlights her. I think he knows precisely what he's trying to
do, but this dude's such a talking about me 24/7 in this
empty human being. He's also forcing his audience to wonder about
CO conspiracy theories, so they already hate him for watching
various videos of what gain of function gene mutations are.
I don't even know what gain of function gene
Um, I'm not using it in a broad way at all. You are advocating
for using it in a broad way yourself. I am using the correct
definition of nuclear unstable. It must be radioactive. Unstable
and reactive are not the same thing. Yes, but in organic chemistry,
especially stability is also used to describe the driving force
kind why some elements or compounds react with other compounds
or elements. For instance, Hold on. But he's not he's not even
disagreeing. This isn't a disagreement.
This is saying but also in another context it could be like different.
It's like, okay, but what context are we in? Uh, mine's really
struggled with this last night, too. I don't know why mine's
why why do you do this? This is a very weird way of arguing.
This is like such a weird way of arguing where it's like, okay,
we have a situation. You're like, well, hypothetically, the situation
was different. It's like, why? No, we don't have to go to a different
situation. Just argue the points. It's like, well, no, I'm trying
to give you a hypothetical if it was like slightly different.
It's like, why?
We're literally arguing about whether or not Ethan Klein is correct
to do what he's doing. We don't have to do a hypothetical about
anything.
Why? Why would we have to do h where where is a hypothetical
required here? What point are you trying to drive home with a
hypothetical?
There is nothing organic chemistry. There are reactions where
high energy intermediates are formed and referred to as unstable
due to their high energy state. Um in this context stability
isn't referred to nuclear stability but energy hybridization
stability.
Oh actually that must be true because when we learned about the
spike protein um I think it uses the phrase I think it's called
thermodynamically stable. Maybe that refers to all kinds of energy
that there are some configurations that are more stable or less
stable or whatever. And that's not talking about the radioactivity
at all. Obviously, the mind guy did not attend the science class
yesterday. Wait, are these out of order? I have a degree in biochemistry.
Maybe the person repeated these. I'm actually believing everything
Destiny says. He also said I'm fat. Is that true? Anyway, here.
Oh, no. He posted his degree. Brother Mines.
Mines is hitting the shell filter. Okay. If this guy talked to
Spinboy, he would show Spinboy his mortgage 100%. He would do
it. He would show him his mortgage. It'd be [__]
crazy. Apparently, I even have BPD. Have I ever said Stacy's
BPD?
Wait, is this all because he said unstable instead of reactive?
Yeah, I described I don't even know what the context was. I don't
know all about chemistry. I hate chemistry. But
yeah, I don't know. I just so funny how obsessive he's arguing
that in chemistry for chemically reactive. They use the term.
Okay, at least I get like
dude, I get to watch like a bigger creator whose audience I love
arguing with, right? What is Destiny getting out of this? What
does he get when he covers all of the Discord messages of Kelly
arguing with a random chatter? Is the viewership good at least?
Is he getting like 10 15,000 viewers for doing this or
what's what's going on? What is the
Term unstable as well. I think I don't know if I argue that ever.
I don't know what the [__] they say in chemistry.
I literally have no idea. But in the context it was used and
my general annoyance with people conflating these two very different
things is me being pedantic. Do you actually think my argument
is stability doesn't just refer to nuclear stability? Uh, Kelly,
um, it is a general principle in chemistry that the more a charge
is dispersed, the more stable is the species carrying the charge.
Um, okay. Carocation, structure, and stability. If you can't
get the point across with a nuclei versus veilance shell, just
let it go before you annoy yourself to a mini stroke. Do you
actually think it's my it has to be because the most abundant
form of sodium that makes up 100% of what is on Earth is not
of an unstable isotope. The nucleus is stable. You would have
to specify unstable to mean chemically reactive which is why
you are yapping about electrons which are what is better to specify
as reactive and not unstable at all or the differentiation in
language is non-existent. Also, you're continuing to Isn't the
Isn't the only thing you have to do here is ask Mines which one
he thinks Destiny was talking
Mines is like arguing that Destiny could be correct in a totally
different context, right? That doesn't apply here. Or maybe he's
not even arguing that. He's he's basically arguing that in another
context you might not be correct.
But it's like, but in this it's like if you have multiple meanings
for the same words, right? Then you'd need to specify what you
mean by it. That's all I was desperately asking at this point.
It's like if you if you're in the like cuz obviously Destiny
didn't do this.
So, he used the word inappropriately in a way that doesn't make
too much sense. Um,
but with mines I was just trying to determine what he was trying
to say because I'm like it's fine if you want to say in chemistry
you can use unstable to mean chemically
but then you'd use it in the context of a conversation where
this would then make sense, right?
You wouldn't just gesture wildly at the periodic table
because that would not make sense. It's like a lot of words require
context for the words to make sense. I I don't know. That's not
like a crazy crazy thing to
to ignore the context actually used for some reason. Why do you
come back to nuclear stability? My argument is there's mult.
Did you see mines got so bullied by the word fat that he posted
his face for? Because the context I've given you that you've
ignored three times. Yes, I did say that. I don't know. Rhox
is correct. I think he's just saying arguing with Kelly should
be bannable. Yeah, I agree. That is true. No. Lol.esting
the periodic table without knowing anything. He brought up the
pen thing again too which is very mad. The entire crux of my
argument is that there's multiple uses for civilian chemistry
claiming that reactivity. How dude not only is this like weird
he's actually skipping so many messages that you couldn't possibly
evaluate this argument, right? Like he's not eval he's skipping
most of the messages now. How are you supposed to evaluate what's
being said? Completely different terms from each other and have
no bearing on each other is ridiculous. Stability and reactive
are so closely aligned that they essentially always follow the
same trends, especially in organic chemistry. Is that true? I
that's true. You are being equally by doubling down by saying
stability only means one super hyper specific thing in the entire
field of chemistry when it doesn't. When you talk to any chemist
ever and refer to something as stable, they're going to ask you
to clarify what you mean by stable because the term isn't a binary.
It's a sliding scale of how a compound behaves based on multiple
different parts of an element or compound. Whether that be nuclear
stability, electron configuration or stereochemistry. I don't
know what stereochemistry means. I'm not being the guy confused
fluoride and florine and called God. I might be able to explain
what stereochemistry is. I I'm flashing back to organic chem.
I hated that [__] A molecule. The same elements.
Highly volatile. None of them were highly volatile either. But
wait, well, sodium is. Are we going to argue that next? No, it's
incredible. Highly volatile. It's like mid. It's like reactivity.
It's like the boiling point, right? You realize
a gaseous state, right?
800 or something Celsius.
Several others. I would have to check the mail. They are mid
at most. Not highly volatile at all. Oh, I didn't even read this
far down.
Kind of mid. Oh, I feel like there's no way he's just free Google
searching either. That's why he pre-watched, right? He wasn't
going to risk like making giving Kelly a W. I think he he's probably
just going to Google something and whatever he Googles will come
up with the exact thing that confirms he's correct. I'm almost
In fact, he said, "What do you mean defaulting on midargument
now?" What do you mean? He said highly volatile.
Sodium's not highly volatile. It's like if you were going to
put all of the elements in a line of volatility, it's somewhere
in the middle. Florine was like his ops communities and that
they were better lameo. He called his community highly unstable
and highly volatile sodium and then said the other communities
were less like this. This is highly volatile things are like
things that are already a gas like room temperature, right? If
it's like I'm not any saying you're just as panic. He said some
objectively things. I will correct them because it will bother
him and he sits around lying about me. So why not? Oh, she's
mad because we call her out now for she made a fake accusation
against her exh Henry. Um probably because she was mad about
getting shot down by some of you guys. Destiny basically allowed
a rule to be made that you couldn't talk about. And basically
said, "Oh, well, I don't know what went on there." Even though
apparently he has this opinion. It's actually the same as the
Mr. Girl thing. It's so funny how spite based Destiny is that
as soon as somebody like turns on him, he'll go like, "Oh yeah,
all the things I ever said to defend you, they were all fake.
I just lied.
Because everybody in the industry realized that she was insane.
Um and then um he came out and he corrected the record on it.
Was he the one who she tried to break into his house after for
not talking to her again? Or was that a different guy afterwards?
I forget. Oh, that's so We're just adding in lies. Hard. He said
just as [__] I've never broke into anyone's house.
Adding in lies. Nothing I said at all. I just made clear what
he was wrong about. I feel like the exclamation mark in their
server is like the new smiley face.
That's he posted his degree and she just demeaned him and kept
arguing. What's wrong with these people? Well, so they have to
have remember like the whole thing about like certain narratives
um and stories about I didn't demean him. He's the one calling
me. I didn't insult this mind's guy. He was insulting me.
How am I the one putting him down?
What the
I was pretty polite to this I hope he doesn't say that. Uh I
hope he doesn't say what I think he's going to The the only reason
I bring this up, the annoying thing is that so if you join these
servers, you always have to side with them about everything.
And this is where the this is like the No, you don't. No, we
literally we literally always argue about this stuff. You don't
have to side with us about everything. You just Hold on. He He's
I I know he's talking to certain people. Okay. You can't be a
consistent
totally wrong shameless [__] Okay. At least man of
the minds if he is wrong about something or if he if he was wrong
about something, he'll go, "Yeah, I was wrong on that." And he
won't come back the next day and be like, "I was actually right
about that the whole time." Right? the there are certain people
who we have banned who will do that behavior and it's like you
are such a disgusting loser. Go away energy vampire. Go away.
Go away. Go away. We don't need you around. Leave. Leave. Leave.
Uh I'm literally describing Yogay right now. Omfg. He's pro.
Like if you literally always get your blown out in every debate
you try to do, you can't prove anything. You just you literally
just fantasize any argument you try to make. Yeah. Just leave.
Just leave, dude. You're so shameless. Leave. Get the out of
here. We don't need you. Okay, but you don't have to agree. We
We're totally fine with arguing. President Sunday. Sunday's not
banned. I didn't even ban Sunday after our last conversation.
I said literally, "Hey, man. I get it. I get I get why you're
upset. You can come back whenever you want. Bye." Antifan manufacturing
plant. This is where they come from because if you spend enough
time in the server, they will constantly harp on you. have to
eventually bend to them or you'll either get banned from the
server or you have to you end up repeating everything they say.
Literally have a channel full of people who are far more offensive
than Yog and it's totally fine with that with that channel. Uh
it's totally fine. We leave those people there. They can argue
their points, you know, the stuff they want to the stuff they
want to argue and then they can join VCs if they want to come
and argue these things. It's What I'm confused by is like this
entire conversation just contradicts what he's saying. Like this
guy came in and disagreed with me for ages and he didn't get
banned or anything.
Like that's just clearly not true. Which is like demonstrated
here.
And this mind's guy is complaining that I was condescending.
Brother, you like
made an argument from authority by bringing it up your like degree
immediately into the conversation. Um I think you were trying
to be condescending too. I don't But I still didn't insult you.
I wasn't rude to you. Yeah. Caruso says, "You can't help but
condescend a brain dead." Well, it's Listen, we explained it
last night to was it Kingler? I think Queen and I both explained
it's like just don't come with an energy like, "Oh, you're wrong
about everything." And then when you show up, you literally can't
actually prove anything you think. All you have is Destiny's
voice in your head telling you something is correct. If you do
that, I will condescend you immediately. Yes, I will treat you
like a complete [__] because that's what you've earned.
You've earned being treated like a complete [__]
You can have shame and say like I don't shame or humility or
you can be intelligent and have some proof. But if you have neither
and if you're indignant about it, yeah, get ready to get made
fun of. And if you do it perpetually, if you have none of those
things, you do that perpetually, get ready to get banned cuz
you're a loser who's wasting everybody's time.
I love the obsession with like not
I just think it's hilarious that Destiny can't not try to disprove
Kelly while trying to make it look like he doesn't care. Laughing.
Where's the obsession with not caring there? I'm I'm literally
saying you yourself care too much about Kelly Jean's opinion
to live a happy life. I live in his head run free. That's By
the way, I said I don't care. I didn't say I don't care about
the fight between Kelly and Destiny. I didn't say I don't care
about like Desi's what Desi said on this. I said I don't care
about chemistry. I don't care about chemistry. I don't care about
electron shells. I don't care about veilance. I don't give a
Shut the up. Get out of my face. Go away. I I'm never going to
use this stuff again. If I want to learn something, I'll go figure
out uh like how the math works behind LLMs or something. That
that would be more interesting to me. Okay, that would be way
infinitely more interesting. I have some background. It could
be like, you know, I could start constructing something that
could be useful to me in the future. Anyway, we continue. You
just realize that that wasn't what I was saying. Someone told
me to post it. I didn't tell you to do that. Man of the minds.
I don't know who did, but it wasn't me. Dude, how is this guy
This guy literally everything he says about me is incorrect.
It's so crazy. How does he How does he up this badly? Out of
cherry. He's Dr. K. True.
He can't help himself. It's so funny. It is so funny. You're
literally You are literally proving my point by reading Discord
screenshots on your stream. Yes, it is funny. This guy really
come in. Did this guy really just show up to piss himself over
Kelly correcting Destiny's chemistry term usage? Imagine the
level your life has to be at. Yeah, exactly. This is just fun.
Seems to be getting genuinely destiny's chemistry term usage.
Imagine the level your life has to be at. Yeah, I was going to
say like after talking about it in your Discord I don't dude
go look for me talking about this in my Discord. I don't talk
about him that much. The fact that we respond to his like stream
clips, but he's desperate to like respond to our Discord messages
and we're the obsessed ones. It's like, bro, this is content.
But like our Discord messages, hundreds of Discord messages,
that's content to you.
Days now, weeks. That's not even content to us. I don't know
why it's content to him. We would
Discord messages. But to go over it twice is the crazy part.
To read through it twice
is the insane thing.
to be like seething about it in DG chat and then go over it again.
That's the cool part. Okay, but God, thank God I just I caught
this right away. We could we can nip it in the bud. Okay, we
don't have to worry about it anymore.
It's
bite driven. Yeah,
you guys, not this stupid cuz he he linked the streamable himself.
Was it before the stream? It must have been before the stream.
He linked the streamable himself and was like, "Wait, am I not
understanding something? Isn't everything in that column of the
periodic table highly reactive?" He didn't say reactive though.
I have it like the hyperfixation on this one word is so obviously
just say you spoke wrong and then let it go. She is being pedantic
or Kelly's going to say that it matters. It what I mean by pedantic
is like you're arguing over something that like could easily
be corrected. Right. So all you got to do is just say I was wrong
and then move That's all you got to do. That's the entire resolution.
If that's what you mean. Yeah. 100%. No, I agree. I think from
my perspective, it's just funny to bully him on this because
he's been trying to learn about like co stuff. I guess he's just
been watching hours and hours of videos and I'm like I don't
think he has a good understanding of the basics involved here.
So that's just kind of funny for me to like wind him up. She's
literally being right and unhinged. True. I feel like also I
am playing back into his hand because I feel like a lot of people
after being forced to read Kelly Jean's Discord messages on stream
after being forced to sit through that. A lot of people are probably
like, "You know what? We should go see this Jay-Z guy. He might
have a point. Okay, this guy's losing it." And then I'm just
covering it back. They're sending him back right
Highly unstable, highly volatile. Sodium is not un
No, Kelly. Guess Destiny's comments made her insecure.
Uh, I had the cap on yesterday and also two days ago.
I think two days ago you literally stood and did a twirl or whatever.
Yeah, but I I feel like she's just not worried about uh this
guy calling her fat, right? I think he's She's probably just
not that worried about it. Oh boy.
She's probably just not that Why would you wear your trousers
like that? I'm like, do you refuse to buy trousers that fit around
the gut? You're like, "I have to get lowrise trousers so I can
like gaslight myself into thinking I wear smaller trousers than
I do." That's like fat woman behavior. I'm not sure men did that.
That's strange. Stable. 100% of all of like the sodium you find
on Earth is the stable isotope of sodium. There is only one naturally
occurring unstable isotope of sodium and it is trace amounts.
Every other unstable isotope of sodium Yeah. is man-made synthetic.
We use one for like PET scans and that has even that only has
like a half life of two and a half Okay. So, okay, all of the
sodium you're ever going to see in your life. I don't call this
guy fat. Cosmic hits. Literally, the first time Kelly called
him fat, I was like, "Oh, I think he's skinnier than me right
now." That's what I said in response.
That's that's literally what I said. I'm sitting here. I'm like,
"Yeah, this is
I mean, if I'm going to be technical, he just has a gut. He just
has a really unfortunate like body composition.
Ah, not for long. He's stress eating.
He's thinking, but it's also a compound. Like, it's salt, right?
Salt is a
Is she thinking of the elements that we've created that only
exist for
Is she actually? She's not. No, the the compound. Okay. The is
Sorry, the isotope. Like when I say that, does she not realize
that the super unstable elements are like I shouldn't call them
fictitious, but the man-made ones at the very end? Is that does
she not realize that's what I'm even referring to? I don't know.
Does he not realize that there are unstable isotopes of all of
the other elements too that we've made?
Didn't you actually point that out before? You literally said
that. I did. You literally said that exact thing and said like
I think he's misunderstanding and not realizing that all of those
man-made the man-made elements he's probably talking about the
end of the periodic table. Like she literally said that he is
literally trying to use Kelly Jean's exact point to sound intelligence
intelligence. Intelligent but I'd also said in like literally
the paragraph before he speaks that I was talking about the unstable
isotope of sodium right so there are synthetic elements that
are earlier on in the periodic table. We've made like synthetic
elements for like a bunch of not just like creating new elements,
but like synthetic isotopes of like um stable long existing elements.
So, he's just a bit I I'm not sure that he didn't know that.
I don't know.
Uh I misspoke and I was just making a good point about him copying
Kelly's exact point and then using that to sound intelligent,
which is very very very funny to me. This woman is so insecure
because people think she's I said intelligence instead of intelligent,
but he's he's basically like this woman's so dumb and she's so
insecure and she wants everybody to think she's smart. I wonder
if she just thinks I wonder if she just doesn't understand that
the unstable elements are at the end of the periodic table. I
wonder if she just doesn't know that. I wonder if she just copying
your exact point to prove that he's smarter than you. Awesome.
You love to see it. There's an isotope of sodium which is unstable.
Well, there's I don't know why she's so hellbent on talking about
isotopes. So I have no idea anything about isotopes. Quickly
clarify
if an element has one occurring
um occurring stable isotope, we consider it stable. But there
are other like when I say at the end of the periodic table, there
are no stable isotopes. But that doesn't mean there aren't unstable
isotopes of like stable elements, right? We've synthetically
made like a lot of Yeah, sure. A weird fixation on an off-handed
comment. 10 or so. I think I can't remember how many hours. All
of those are really I just find this really interesting. I love
talking about this stuff. How is he not like getting like my
enthusiasm coming across? Like I just love yapping about and
like making everyone suffer. Like this is great. Like and I've
always done this. I've always like autistically spoke about whatever
I find interesting for like periods of time. And occasionally
I do hold people hostage doing that. Uh, but in this case, I
did actually ask for permission in advance before I help people
hostage. Okay, true. I'm sitting here in like psychic pain. I'm
giving Kelly her time because she asked for it and she helps
me sometimes when when I'm in like if I want to watch something,
I'm sure there's some things where she's like, I wish I wasn't
here right now. Okay. So, I can the least I can do is sit here
while Kelly talks about something she Hockey discussion. I did
make her watch the I did make her watch NHL highlights during
the playoffs. That's true.
That was torture. This is Yeah, this is Yeah, I did that.
sodium that we use for PET scans into salt. But you could you
could make a compound salt of that same sodium. But if you ate
it, you'd probably get Oh, the other thing I was going to say
is, yes, Kelly is enjoying this. Everyone else is in psychic
pain. So, Destiny, for the love of God, stop reacting to this.
Everybody needs out. Okay. Everybody needs out. This is only
serving Kelly's needs and wants. Okay. When you react to Kelly,
you're only helping Kelly. You're hurting yourself. You're hurting
me. You're hurting everybody in both chats. Okay. Stop.
I'm having a great time. I'm sure a lot of people actually enjoy
Kelly's chemistry lessons. So, so I wouldn't recommend it because
it would be
He's seething so much. He's seething so much. He's literally
watching and
Oh, no. He tweeted that. Wait, didn't Nak make this? This is
your fault, bro. What is the sodium isotope?
Can something decay back into like just an ordinary like can
an isotope decay back into like the the default stock element
or uh it can do, but it would have to be metastable to decay
into itself. It would release an energy, but that wouldn't be
in this case. And uh it can decay in every direction. It doesn't
have to just decay down. It can decay to the side.
So that's the decay ladder like um is interesting. Yeah, whatever.
I'm sure he doesn't actually care about me answering that question,
but I like talking about it. So there you go. Someone should
get the sidebyside of when Kelly stood up to Destiny's gut. Okay,
compare guts. Let's compare guts. Somebody get the picture.
Throw it up. Throw up the comparison. Yeah, dude. Does it just
decay back into like the ordinary? Does it even matter? Emitting
radiation, right? Probably don't make radioactive salt wouldn't
be my recommendation. Google sodium decay paths isotope. You
could make radioactive solar. I just think it would be fun.
Again, I need to drive home what is so funny here to me is that
he can't just stop reacting. He had just move on and let Kelly
like whatever. I don't know chemistry, so I don't care, right?
He actually has to go and try to look up things she's saying
to figure out things she could be wrong on cuz he can't let it
go. He cannot let it go ever. It's why he has to read all the
Discord logs. It's why he has to reference every single time
Kelly's ever called him fat. He just cannot let it go. It upsets
him. Said it's a compound. It upsets him. And like, by the way,
sometimes I'm like, you know, I don't know. I don't know if I
like streaming all that much sometimes. A little bit. I'm like,
you know, I don't really I don't know if I like streaming all
that much. And then Destiny just gives me a reason to like fire
up the stream and go eight hours. Okay. You know, I I kind of
I didn't get that much prepared today. I only have like three
hours of content. No, let's go eight hours. It Why not? A thousand
years Destiny content. Okay,
post yourself side by side with Destiny. I'm I literally already
said I'm fat. That's what I said. I don't I don't want to compete
in this. Okay, I'm not posting my face with a bunch of psychopaths
hunting me. No thank you. No thank you. But I I also am like
I literally am opting out and saying, "No, I'm fat. No,
Imagine singing for this dumb who wanted to Destiny. Sorry, who
is that? Because if you're trying to talk about me, I'm the only
one that did not Destiny nor want to. So, you're you're talking
to the wrong person. I'm sorry.
No, no, hold on. I think I looked at that gut and I was like,
"No, I'm reading a chat message."
I'm saying I'm like fatter than uh whatever this was probably.
That's all I'm saying. Anyway, that's where the bar
Kelly does not make that that sodium by Wait, are you saying
hello to me or are you saying hello on the video? I can't even
tell now.
is the same as sodium chloride. Yes, I'm saying I wouldn't recommend
making that compound and eating it, but you could if you wanted
to. You might get a bit in trouble. Is it costing him anything
going over this besides making you laugh? Uh, so I do this because
it's funny to my community. I get big community participation
when I do this. So, it's basically always good if Destiny is
like seething about us. It's always good. I don't think Destiny
gets anywhere near the participation on his end. And I need to
make money from streaming. I I need to make money for my job.
So sometimes people talk about me. I can't avoid it. I should
go I should go fight with them because that's best for me. Right.
For him, he could walk away. He's like a millionaire. He could
do whatever he wants. But he he decides to do this. But I mean,
if he wants to give me free content, I love it. You love to see
it. Is it a bad move going over this? Maybe not. Seems like it
is, but maybe not. Did he have really high viewership for it?
Maybe he did. There is no penetration.
I'm not being pedantic. No, you are being pedantic.
Oh, this is the pedantic argument. This is just funny weird penetration
I'm not being pedantic. No, you are being pedantic because trying
to call you when you're correct, right? It's like you know the
technical details of something and somebody's like, "Oh, you're"
and so you're like, no, pedantic."
Pedantic would be pointing out something that's not important
within the context of something. The things that he's saying
I believe to be important.
So, I don't feel like I'm being pedantic. I am bringing this
up to annoy him because it's annoyed him.
But I Oh, I didn't mean to start a pedantic conversation on penetrry.
So, let's I'm not being pedantic and or nitpicky. I know exactly.
Unstable and reactive are like two entirely different things.
Like unstable is like the the nucleus, right? And reactivity
is the electrons. Yes, these are two things. One is chemical
Yeah, I don't know. That's not being pedantic. You you also say
you did pantic and get into a pantic argument this is not pedantry.
This is teaching because he doesn't know the fundamentals of
the things that he's speaking about. There's also another reason
of why I wanted to mention that. But that's fine. Well, I No,
this is just funny because this is just incredibly is watching.
We saw that Desi's watching and tweeting. It's very very very
funny. Funny to me because incredibly funny. This would be nothing
if Desi could just go, you know what? I didn't really know what
I'm saying. I don't really know. Let's be clear. The very first
I don't [__] with. I still maintain that. No, you
didn't do that. You didn't do that. And I started making fun
of you for being unable to do that at the very start of this
clip. You did not do that right away. You did not do that right
away. He just rewrites history and all of the in his chat eat
it up totally. I don't at some point I think when he keeps sending
people here and he like totally rewrites history, refuses to
say anything that's like true, he just totally lies maliciously
or even lies. I don't even know if he realizes he's lying. I
don't know if he is just so used to having a cult that his lies
get turned into reality for them. I actually don't know what
it is, but I think that like if he sends enough of these people
here over time and we just continuously show how he's lying.
By the way, we showed the Anna screenshots earlier today again.
All right.
If if if
it just keeps happening over and over and over again, eventually
they'll see that he's just lying, that he's just maliciously
lying all the time, making things up, that he's kind of he's
kind of just embarrassingly egotistical to a point that he can't
really he can't do valid criticism of us. It seems like almost
at all. And there are so many valid things to criticize. That's
the funny thing. My community can light me up. Destiny just always
Destiny just instead of actually instead of actually like criticizing
me or watching a clip and criticizing a point, he actually just
makes things up about me all the time. It's very I really don't.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Words have meaning. Exactly what that guy
said.
And scientifically, the meanings are more important colloquially.
Scientifically, no one here is talking about like a paper we're
publishing. Bro, I made a comment that some communities were
very reactive. That's literally it. That's that was all it You
didn't say reactive. That's the
reactive and unstable in a sentence, you could they would be
interchangeable. Which is why if you were to Google is sodium
um stable, it would probably say no because it's reactive because
it doesn't differentiate. Does she have any degrees or anything?
she just has a bunch of fake.
Unlike you who doesn't disability money while she abuses alcohol
every day on the stream and then sells because I'm an alcoholic.
He's so he's so assigned that he got blown out on this thing,
right? that he was that Kelly's is far more correct than him
that like Kelly's just correcting him and there's really no way
that you can try to pick at what she's saying, right? He's so
pain that now he's just going to do everything he knows that
anything you could possibly do to try to upset Kelly, he's going
to try to throw them all in here. And just know, Destiny, that
no matter how many of these things you throw in, every time Kelly
calls you fat, it will annoy you a 100 times more than she's
annoyed right He's already said everything he could. There is
nothing else to say other than making up lies. And lies don't
affect me because they're not true. So hold on. I have to point
out that
Oh, just one more thing, Kelly. I just have to point out that
um there is somebody who you should all watch if you're a DJ
and you're here. Okay, there is somebody you should watch. All
right, and this is mostly based on I I realized this the other
day and I had to point it out. Okay, Destiny's patchy, disgusting,
balding beard. Okay, I noticed that there's basically there's
basically somebody who uh who has like a painted on beard. Look
at how full this beard is. Oh my god. Oh my god. This beard is
so full. It's like it's painted on. Like the medicated. Oh my
god. You guys should Why does anybody watch Destiny when you
could watch this guy who works harder, who's never going to jeopardize
his movement by uh revenge boarding his friends? Sorry, not revenge
warning. By non-conensually sharing pictures and non-conensually
recording people in situations. He's never going to jeopardize
his movement doing those things. He's always going to have the
facts on his side. He's always going to make good points, right?
He works hard. He is based. That beard is basically painted on.
Oh my god. I think you could draw one to one with Destiny's patchy
disgusting beard and Pisco's painted on one. You just know who
the better commentator is. Okay. Oh my god. Can we get Pisco
fan cams? I need an actual Pisco fan cam. Okay. I need a Pisco
fan
cuz this guy has mogged Destiny in every possible dimension.
Oh my god.
I just wanted to throw that in in case Die is still watching
so he can see more. Good luck. Oh, also all of that was true.
He was a way better commentator than you. He cares. He actually
is like moral He is actually like morally invested in his positions,
right? He's just better than you in every dimension. So, good
luck. Everybody's going to realize it. You're slowly going to
bleed audience to him over time. 5 years from now, he'll still
exist. You will no longer be on the internet. Good luck. The
only real thing Destiny is upset about is that he can't bully
and hurt you like he used to. I mean, yeah, but this is just
fun. I know. It's really fun for me. Just Nicole might find it
kind of boring, but like the back and forth is funny. Like, we
don't really lose anything from this. Destiny just gets to listen
to a whole bunch of where he looks kind of dumb and he has to
read out Destiny is fat and look at that in like a hundred different
screenshots. It's just like
don't really lose in this
Oh, sorry. I'm being told to bring this picture up of the the
Is the other side falling out now, too?
We definitely have our whole strip still taken out here, but
is the other side also falling out now?
Are we losing all of it? Are we losing everything? Is everything
everything is going?
Everything is being lost. Bro, I I find it really funny that
a bunch of DJ years are like, "No, Pisco is not going to be popular.
Pisco is not going to be anything. Pisco is nothing." Oh, Mantis
must hate Pisco, too, because Pisco totally embarrassed Tom,
right?
I think that must be I forgot that. I was like, why would Mantis
not like Bisco? It's cuz Pisco totally mogged Tom
Yikes. Oh, okay. No, she says that's fake news. She likes Pisco.
You slandered Mantis there. That's You know what? That's based
when Pisco pointed out that Tom was so bad at arguing that he
had convinced Pisco that Pisco is even more right than when they
begun the debate. I
I thought that was awesome. Okay, Pisco Pisco is awesome. We
love that guy. We didn't necessarily love that guy uh before
when he was in DGG, but now that we see the world clearly, oh,
Pisco is just so much better than Destiny. He's so much better
in every
two times because it's an AI. I never dislike Pisco. I always
loved arguing with Pisco. He did not like me That doesn't understand
what you're
So, yes. Kelly, don't misspeak. Otherwise, you will never live
it down. Have I done so far? Why would I? Because I know where
I'm doing video. I think Yes. Go for it. Oh, there he is. Oh,
he had to he had to Google Florine to find out where Florine
was on it. Does he not have eyes?
Like, what are we doing here? That is very funny. Hold on. That
is very funny
that he like literally looked through the periodic table and
could not tell. He like he was like, "Oh, I can't find this."
And he like opened Google to look. It's incredibly funny to me
because like I feel like I don't know anything about chemistry
and I like see him Google that and then he's like, "Oh, there
it is. Number nine."
Number nine. There it is.
Here it is.
What do you want in Okay, here. No, no, no. No, no, no. Don't
run out again. No. Here. Look. You can have the bathroom door
open. Here. You're not There's literally nothing in here. Cat's
trying to save him from speaking further. This cat is trying
to save him so many times. It is It's not Oh.
why is my chemistry so important now? I'm so confused. Um, there's
a lot of things that Kelly is insecure about, so she wants to
pretend that people like her for more than just her spamming
luds or whatever or streams and looking. I would never pretend
that people like Skip back to the beginning of this. We must
just skip back. No, it was just
the same point he had from before.
You just watched a clip of this. It was the first thing you watched
was just a
Stuck to a weird place cuz she has to show streams to show that
she's not fat even though she's angling her. Oh, I see. This
is a clip. I see. I got it. When my weight has changed for the
past two years. Uh, but part of that also she also has to show
not only she not fat, she's also very intelligent and the reason
why people like her is but she's intelligent and funny and not
just
everybody how stupid I am and [__] I am and how smart
she I just can't imagine starting a sentence with like Kelly
just needs to be liked by everybody. I I feel like I would have
to go to bed for the night. Like I I would have I would have
probably been, you know, on my way to the bathroom to vomit because
I'd have to have like 12 drinks to ever utter a statement that's
stupid, right? Like I must have said that, you know, Kelly just
wants everybody to like her. Yeah, I would probably be on my
way to the bathroom to puke. Severe alcohol poisoning is the
only excuse for that Can you imagine? Good god. Thinking that
I would do anything like that. I do do to be liked versus I like
doing things and I'm happy to make other people suffer.
Yes, this guy is he's picked an iron.
What? What?
I understand not knowing what a lot of other elements that we
really don't see in real life mean. But like some of the stuff
that you interact with on a daily basis, I feel like probably
you should know how it [__] works.
Like what even what does that comment mean? If you interact with
an element or a compound on a daily brush, but I don't ever interact
with you at any point in my life. Well, maybe I have one like
there's just like so many weird like pseudo intellectual statements
made like how could you not know the underlying properties of
the isotopes of a
I agree with Destiny here. Hold on. Me human. Me human. Uh just
so you know, that was literally my point from the very beginning
was that there's just no reason for Destiny not to go I don't
know chemistry and Kelly's like Kelly doesn't know what she's
talking about,
100 viewer bump tweet shake dog paying for the ad space. Oh yeah,
that would be funny if you guys go spam my link under his tweet.
That would be pretty funny.
That would be funny. How some of these things interact does have
practical uses because like you use some of these things in your
daily life. Like if you mix chlorine and bleach, you're going
to like gas yourself to death in your bathroom. It's like it's
a good thing to know like what things interact with and why and
just like a basic amount of like information I feel. But like
I don't know that's just me I guess maybe I I don't know the
the important things. Somebody's car so annoying. Logistical's
like no I don't clean. Oh no. I don't think that's I don't think
that's valid. I think uh most people should just look at Mitch
bleach with uh well they should just like knock themselves out
and learn the hard way. No, it's just like you should learn that
through other means other than having to learn chemistry because
most people aren't really capable. But that's fine. But that
that is like a practical application of uh chemistry knowledge,
right? That's what I mean. I'm not saying that you need to h
never mind. I knew what I meant.
OMG. That's the periodic table memorized. That's not what the
criticism is. The criticism is when he goes, "You know what?
Uh Kelly's wrong. I was talking about sodium. And I like how
Cher's like mental has to try so hard to defend uh Kelly the
streamer honor to keep the segment going. This whole inter Wait,
I I just made the same points the whole time. Why is he pretending
that my position has ever changed?
I'm like
so consistent on everything I'm saying here. It's so funny. It's
very very very entertaining to me. If I am a stream for talking
about this stuff, then isn't he just people by covering us? I
think he was talking about me to be fair there. But wait. Oh,
wait. How does that No, he said something about me and the stream.
I don't What did he say then? He did not.
I'm not going to go back. Go back. Yeah, go back cuz I have no
idea what he doesn't have the periodic table memorized. That's
not what the criticism is. The criticism is when he goes, "You
know what? Uh, Kelly's wrong. I was talking about sodium. And
I like how Cherry's like mental has to try so hard to defend
uh Kelly the streamer honor to keep the segment going
Oh, he did call you the streamer. That is true, Kelly. I missed
that one.
But uh
the whole point here is I I'm just laughing. I'm sitting the
sidelines and saying I don't care who is correct or wrong. I
think one of these people comes on stream for fun sometimes and
the other person makes thousands of dollars per stream. And that
guy who makes thousands of dollars per stream can't handle the
uh the other person having anything over them, having like any
amount of superiority in any way. So they will spiral on this
for hours and hours and hours and hours and hours,
right? They'll read it off stream. They'll read all of those
Discord messages off stream. They'll watch this entire segment
off stream and then they will do it all again on stream
and and he won't feel any shame about it. Not even an ounce of
shame. Yeah, that is true. I'm here for purely love of the game
only. There is no other Ben. It's just my enjoyment. This is
very sad. But Flory, if I had more time, I would hate watch the
stream all day. Okay. And it's like he doesn't know where it
is on the table. His argument, I believe, was supposed to be,
oh, it's part of the same group, but he didn't know where it
was. It's not even on the table. That's why it's funny. Why it's
buddy? It's so silly. Yeah. He's going to engage with that, right?
He's going to engage with what he said. He's going to he's going
to not totally avoid what he said, right? Cuz I I just explained
what it was. He was saying, "Oh, well, there's basically no difference
between these two things because they're in the same group."
Is Is that not what he said? Maybe I'm wrong. I thought that
was like his whole point from the beginning. These two things
are in the same group. I I made a statement about one of them.
It kind of applied to the other or one of the things he said,
I guess. He also made the points about reactivity or whatever.
I He said as much at the beginning of this clip. he said as much
at the beginning of this Lori turns the frog's gay. Damn, true.
I think it's almost done. It's Here's a Here's an easier way
to put it. He is so angry when when somebody tells calls him
wrong, but he's even angry when Kelly Jean calls him wrong that
he will argue from a place of total ignorance in in light of
that, right? He will argue from a place of total ignorance and
say wrong things and then he will cope perpetually trying to
make it so that he wasn't as wrong as he was, right? Including
up to including saying, "Guys, I was just trying to learn it.
I really I wasn't saying anybody was right or wrong here."
You know what's additionally annoying? that he hasn't spent any
time offream like learning about the things that I've been speaking
about just to prove me wrong. He thought that his ego is big
enough that he could just do it on the fly
despite having said so many silly things prior cuz I I don't
get the impression that he's looked anything up in advance. He's
been sent a bunch of stuff and he's just like Kelly is so stupid.
I can just immediately correct her and then it's just this and
then he just has to insult me by like bringing uh like lying
about stuff or Yeah. Kelly and Jtock are contradicting each other
here. In what way?
Yeah, I don't know how how are we how are we contradicting each
other? I actually Yeah, bro. So, somebody says chemical properties
are very similar if they're in the same group. That's like you
can always tell when people do this like nothing statement, this
like total nonsequiter in my chat while we're watching a Destiny
segment. Those are always covert DJers who like are a little
embarrassed that they like Destiny. They don't want to come here
and say it, but they'll do these like weird nonsequittors not
related to anything at all. Right. And then and then they'll
pretend they'll tell themselves that I just made a meaningful
statement that shows that actually Destiny is not crazy. Said
elements in the groups. Yes. The funny thing was was he tried
to use that piece of knowledge you just stated. He's pro incorrectly.
Yes. You said Destiny. No, no, no. Kingler, I see. Also, Kingler
is like this as well. Oh, Kingler, you'll you'll fix yourself
one day. I believe in you. Okay. I'm not even going to be mean
here. What Kelly said was he didn't take any time to study the
chemistry to prove she's wrong. He just has an ego. So, he's
going to go and try to prove without looking up any of the chemistry.
He's going to look at these logs and try to explain on the fly
why he's correct.
I said he went and looked at the logs. He went and prepared the
segment, right? He watched the VOD. He's looking at the logs.
He's trying to get ready for this. It was obvious throughout
the entire segment. And then he comes here and that makes him
a loser because he's watching my Listen, he's watching. He's
watching my twice. He's going through my Discord for logs. It's
embarrassing. It's incredibly embarrassing for him. But hey,
maybe you guys think that's awesome. I hope you think that's
awesome. I certainly like my content, so I'm glad that Destiny's
a fan, too. Wait, those those statements are also totally uh
they're not mutually exclusive whatsoever, right? Reading the
logs and preparing the logs is not reading the chemistry.
You guys are so mad because you lovely people.
That was that was the end of it.
Who hangs out with people IRL? Is this is this the one? Wait,
which one you want, Kelly? You got to tell me. Um I mean, we
can watch that one since you've already passed away. Yeah, they
hate strange man. Just makes him look weird. Not me. Does she
not remember? Didn't we go over this at the time when I went
to that hay festival thing in uh Wales? She literally Oh god,
we have 30 more minutes.
Yeah, he did uh a whole hour of ranting.
He invited herself to that.
She ruined my whole I wanted to talk to the guy. She ruined all
the Oh my god me. Oh, what was what was her question? I had some
because I sound I listened to an hour of him and another person
another physicist talk.
I feel like I have to skip this. Uh, I had some question about
his presentation and I couldn't ask it because Kelly asked him
a Google question and sat there and listened for 30 minutes to
tell you Kelly understand.
Oh, that's in the video. Can you imagine saying Kelly didn't
understand all of that when you thought fluoride was on the periodic
table and you called sodium unstable
like Kelly is the one that doesn't understand things here. She
couldn't possibly I wasn't talking about the double split experiment
either. That's like that's also Yeah, exactly. I was talking
about another duality in particle physics. I'm sorry. My bad.
I don't know why that just came out. Of course.
And I linked him this article to try to explain it to him, but
he was too dim to understand what I was saying. Do I have my
idea? What? What did she even link me? How long ago was this?
I don't even know what um Oh, no. Cuz her her Discord got banned
for the whatever child [__] What would a message
have been that she'd sent me that I remember? Huh? I could link
it to you again, Destiny, if you're interested.
What was the city that that Well, you can just Google a new duality
and particle physics and the articles. I know it's 22 or 23,
one of these. I think it's 2022.
Who cares? Went to go watch his thing next. Uh, and he also messaged
me before I went cuz I I messaged him saying, "I'm thinking of
going to this event." And before he left or maybe just Yes, I
mode. Exactly. This is like the funniest thing to me. I'm sitting
here and I'm like, "Dude, I want to go cover this dance stuff."
Okay. And instead, I'm sitting here and it's like I'm just watching
this guy see. This guy went from Okay. from like actual intellectuals
like wanting to talk to him. And now the best he can do is he
can't even get Kellyan in his Discord. He has to start like react
reacting back and forth with Kelly Jean. Okay. That's where he's
at now. Yeah. And tweeting about how how funny he thinks dead
kids are. Cool. This guy's He's been he's been doing that today.
Oh yeah. He's been tweeting a lot about dead kids. Been mocking
conservatives for kids dying and Yeah. 100%. He literally said
two days ago, h how am I
Yeah, tweeting about dead kids. That was the That was the funny
thing was he was like, "How am I sociopathic? Just show me one
DM." And we just pull up the Anna DMs and it's like, "Remember
when this person had like clearly had some like obsessive tendencies,
some obsessive spiraling they were doing. And you were saying,
"Oh, well, I'll fix the obsession. I'll fix the thing you're
obsessing over. Just let me like have these with you, okay? Let
me talk about rubbing your feet, your legs and your feet for
you. Okay, you just lay in the bed and I'll rub your legs and
feet for you and she's like clearly still spiraling about it,
right? You're calling her a stalker while her because you're
a psychopath. Sociopath, sorry, sociopath was the word he used.
Yeah, Say you got there, you messaged me saying, "Oh, are you
coming or are you there?" One of the two. So I Oh, it's so cringe.
So my contention is like she tried to invite herself basically.
And I like how she cites me trying to like um trying to be like
polite as evidence of me wanting to be there. So I think she
messaged me about coming and I was like oh and I think after
I got to the festival and I was already there um then I responded
like oh um are you here yet or did you end up coming or whatever?
I want to have anything in advance. Oh but she she was there
on her own so I was like well [__] me but I like
she like evidence of oh I didn't want to see someone probably
message that. I don't know just saying. Isn't that Wait, she
went on her own because she was interested in the
Yeah. She was like, "Oh, you're going to be here. That would
be cool."
And also I technically I wasn't on my own because I went like
up in a car with two other people.
Um like I granted I didn't know them very well, but I had known
of them and knew that they were going to the festival. So we
drove up and also I stayed for longer at the festival and went
to like the XE talk the next day and got like my book signed
and stuff. So, I I don't know. Crazy that Kelly would go to a
public event where there are other people and other things going
on like wild. I don't know. Very crazy.
Wow. Why does Kelly has to have this will to come off super smart?
Nothing I've said really in any in the last 10 minutes or however
long this has been has been anything you wouldn't know if you
weren't asleep during like high school science lessons. I don't
You learn what compound is when you're like 11 or 12. I I I don't
know what to say. The fact that he doesn't know like basic doesn't
make me smart. It makes him stupid. I'm pointing Hold on. Destiny,
you kept it on your stream for years. What does this cope
Um I literally I already explained this. I said it in the picture
to multiple people and I ended up saying this on stream and it
ended up being true. The reason why there was I mean like I didn't
mind playing League with Kelly and maybe for a little bit after
that it was fine. This was like eight years ago. But the problem
with Kelly is that there were a few people Kelly and Lav two
of them. I call them Discord queens. These are usually unemployed
women that make money through either disability or men paying
for their honestly no. As much as I disagree with Kelly Jean
on basically everything, she's honestly a really good person.
Like I think almost pixie levels of being nice courteous to people,
December
December 20 has mark now
bring out these same three things just to drive the point home
into his brain.
I don't understand why I don't understand why he like loses his
mind about this. It's so stupid. Like just stop making things
up or just say you lie at other I I don't know. You contradict
yourself so heavily all the time. It's so go it's so goofy.
Why would you say these things? What were what was the point
of this?
What was the purpose of this message? Yeah. Also,
who the was he talking about?
Anyway, we continue. Oh, whoops. That was the clip. That's the
clip. They will sit on Discord literally all day. They will sit
on Discord all day and on you and they will become permanent
haters. And the reason why I didn't eject because the closest
I came to ejecting Kelly from orbit I think um before I actually
did I think was over the honest stuff like this is just you're
insanely on hinge but but even at that end because I knew because
but I knew that this would happen because this is exactly why.
So it's just um having there are certain types of people in life
that are annoying to oh uh oh uh Destiny didn't eject Kelly from
his orbit because she would she become his most unhinged hater.
It's actually the Anavar situation in his head again. Okay. He's
saying Kelly Jean had Destiny trapped in the basement of her
mind. Okay.
Destiny was trapped. He just He couldn't do it, guys. He had
a gun to his head, guys. Guys, he had a gun to his head. Okay.
He just had to keep Kelly around because if if he kicked her
out, that would have been so much worse. Don't you understand?
Pick up as a celebrity influence, Just say like, "Oh, we ended
up having like a a friendship ending argument over stuff." And
yep, that's how it goes. I I don't know why. Why do we have to
pretend you like hate? Well, although he did he's just duplicitous.
I don't even know how to track his opinion because I I'm pretty
sure I've heard about him talking about her behind closed doors,
too. He's just duplicitous and weird. And they're like, I would
believe that on the basis that he's done that to like a lot of
other people, right?
So, probably seems pretty two-faced.
Nothing going on in their lives. So, um Kelly's one of those
people who will forever be somebody for the next like decade
who will hang around. You just read her Discord logs. You literally
went and read all of her Discord logs twice. Off stream and then
on stream. You read all of the logs,
I knew if I kicked Kelly from orbit, she would force me to record
and distribute media without consent. This is all Kelly's fault.
It is all Kelly's fault, guys.
And how is it? How is it?
I'm saying I'm saying like the opposite. I'm saying like Destiny
has money. Why is he doing this? And he's like, "These people
suck. These people are such losers. They have nothing going on
that I have to sit here and see about them. I have to I have
to cover them off stream. I have to cover them on stream. I have
to see all the time about them. I like that doesn't make any
sense. That doesn't that that makes no sense. What are we doing?
Discords are just constantly talk about me. Like you saw that
immagly
talks about me constantly. And it's just annoying to have people
like this always working in the background. Also because they're
guaranteed to have some admittance in communities because they're
always willing to spam pictures of themselves themselves and
check for He is stupid. Not that I am smart. Okay. I'm just like
quickly maybe that surprise to Lav, but go
Does he think that like going over all of the immig
content? Does he think that's going to make me shut up? If he
doesn't want me to talk, why does he keep turning this into content?
Oh, like, are we supposed to like not go over it? I'm baffled.
Uh, I wasn't necessarily going to go over it, but I literally
Kelly can Kelly knows. I'm literally like, "Hey, if you're interested
in this stuff, we can cover it, but otherwise I'm going to go
to like the Nick stuff, and we won't go to it later. So, if you
want to go over that's not what I that's not what I asked. The
point is like, if he doesn't want us to keep yapping and talking
and turning stuff into condom, why would he keep doing it?" Like,
that doesn't It's like nonsensical, right? Just he could easily
just stop talking about me. Exactly. I'm being disingenuous there.
It was more like, "Hey, Kelly, you're here right now. I know
you won't be here later. I'm not going to cover this stuff later
if you don't want to, but we could cover it now." Uh, I'm not
against covering it cuz obviously people love it, okay? Number
go up. Number go up when we watch Destiny about us, okay? Every
single time without fail. So, realistically, it's like, yeah,
I'm like down for it. But I I mostly don't I It's just like a
principal thing. Like, why? Look at this person's like weird
patchy beard. Makes me physically like ill, like nauseous. Like
I have to I have to take gravel just to get through this stream
right now. Okay. This up anyone that paid attention in school
but now most of these things I don't.
Okay. Was that was that everything Kelly or we continue going?
Was the honest stuff? Um there was some there's a girl that hang
out with Anna. Um and I don't I don't even know what happened.
I don't know what I don't think I had any conflict but Kelly
just basically started throwing out like unhinged female comments
about her. I think it might be Hold on. Can I can I No, no, no.
Okay, go. No, like quickly. He's already gone over this in the
last few days. I genuinely think the early onset Alzheimer's
might be kicking in because he's just Is he not remembering that
he said all of these same things in the last two days already?
Like why is he going over it
I'm not sure. But um dude, it's it's so funny that he's like
I I just don't know. Like Anna didn't really even do anything.
No, Anna basically gave away that you were talking Kelly in private.
Anna gave the game away, right? that you were trying to talk
Kelly to her in private, a thing you've done with multiple other
people. And Kelly was like, "Oh, that looks like she came out
of a dumpster. Those tattoos are disgusting." And you lost your
mind. Yeah. I mean, actually, I what I said was funnier than
that. I said it looks like her tattoos were done with random
trash on the floor. It was like, "What dumpster does she get
out?" It wasn't like for some reason he says, "That's me calling
her a prostitute." And I'm like, "No, that's me saying she looks
like trash."
because of like a literal meaning.
I don't really know any dumpsters where prostitutes live, but
hey, who knows? This guy says, "You realize the more he reacts
to you, the better for him, right? He has to show you with infinitely
higher viewers than you'll ever get." Uh, okay. I think he had
what, five, six times the viewers for this VOD or something.
I don't know if we'd call that infinite. What do we have? Uh,
maybe maybe
seven, eight times the the number of viewers. Is that like is
that that much? I you're saying infinite?
I don't know. I I feel pretty comfortable with this. I think
this is a good trade-off for me. And I get an infinite pipeline
of cult members to humiliate on stream for free content.
Thank you, Destiny. Thank you. Let's go. I don't know what I
don't think I had any conflict, but Kelly just basically started
throwing out like unhinged female comments about her in um in
another Discord about how she looked like some prostitute that
I found at a dumpster. I was just like, "This girl never said
anything mean to Kelly." Ever called her a prostitute? I called
her a prostitute. [__] comments. And then when she
came on to But even you did it indirectly to be fair, but I didn't
even do it indirectly at this point. He's just losing his
It was the one of the most manipulative pieces of shadow conversations.
That was the first conversation where I like literally called
out every single time like, "Why are you saying this? This is
super manipulative. Why are you doing this?" Um, it was probably
one of the most like upfront comos I think I've had with her.
But oh, actually
find the date. I remember the day the day that it was too much.
I decided I hated Kelly. Um, she went a different for years after
it was when I think it was during the Orbiter Infinity Wars period
and something happened. I don't remember what it was. Somebody
made some comment about Kelly being uh in my Discord room and
um she was like wasting a slot in the call or something. Something
like this. I thought Destiny Sorry. When he covered this, sorry,
Destiny could have high views, right? Obviously, but I think
when he's covering this, didn't he have like 5k views or something?
Am I crazy? I thought somebody told me he had like 5k viewers
covering this.
So, yeah. I he could easily adore, but I guess he wants to cover
Discord stuff happen. I don't remember or she didn't say anything.
It was something like I like it. And then I guess to prove wrong,
she decided to Oh, because Ch was making fun of her, she decided
to join the Discord call in like the most whatever leggy revealing
outfit she could and then sit in the call for like six hours
and said absolutely nothing but try to just be in the background
so people would say nice things about her again. Um and
reason to hate me for Oh my god, that was so annoying. Somebody
can go and find that um go and find that VOD or can we just like
sit and think? Sorry, can you pause for a sec? He's saying he
dislikes me because I was relatively quiet and had my cam on.
That's that's that's his big reason for hating me apparently.
I have no recollection of what the he's talking about, but he's
just mad because I was attractive on a video and didn't say much.
I'm just one insane reason to dislike someone
and not say anything about it at the time at all. Yeah, sure.
Sure. As somebody just pointed out, I feel like he married somebody
who did that for a living. So, I don't know. I don't know. He's
uh very very strange. I think she calls nothing. Oh my god.
This guy is like a Nobel physicist. Okay. 91 years old. Very
intelligent guy. Very interesting guy. Listen here. He goes back
and forth and the panel is incredibly mis
he's talking about this thing. I'm sorry. I so don't care about
your festival thing. I like so don't care. I don't care. He rambled
a lot. I just super don't care. I don't care about hockey, but
here we I know. I know. It's so It's so stupid. I'm sorry. It's
so stupid. I'm sorry if there's like a really good point there.
I apologize. That's the one thing I'm cutting it at. Okay. I
can't do the
if you want. I mean, you could just watch this video overall.
It's not that long and it's got like some mentions of other [__]
in it. I don't know. Do you want to do that and just watch the
whole You want to watch the whole thing? Sure. Let's watch. By
the way, another another indication that he uh that he watches
the stream cuz he knew to cut it right here, right? It's so funny.
I just like content other Kelly planned. Kelly planned. Okay.
Kelly knew. She was like, "Hey, we should watch this." And then
uh there's this vod from a couple days ago if you want to watch
this. That's That's like 30 seconds of effort, which is a hundred
times more effort than Kelly normally puts into like pre-planning
streams. Okay. Excuse me. I did a Google doc, I think, with a
few things. That's I'm saying it was really good. Sorry, I said
30 seconds, but um you you put she put actual effort into the
stream and I was like, "Oh, I want to Yeah, I'll go through this
stuff." And then she was like, "Oh, we can just watch this whole
video." And I'm like, "Yeah, sure. You you're aware of this.
Let's go to the whole thing." Kelly reaction to the break from
too much science because I feel like everyone's getting mad.
So, there you go. Kelly teaching us will ultimately be the downfall
of your I have no I can't correct her and I don't have enough
of an ego that I have to be like no I know chemistry well enough
to say she's correct. I'm literally just never going to have
an opinion. It can't possibly affect me in any way except because
they don't want to listen to Kelly talk about chemistry. That's
the only way it could affect me and I don't if you guys think
I'm wrong about something just at me and message me it will respond
to you. I uh who cares if Kelly is correct? I do cuz it's funny.
We like winding up Destiny and making him see. Kelly's on stream.
Kelly up. Kelly's helping me out. So Kelly gets some time to
explain what she thinks sodium is to people. It's not even what
I'm doing.
I'm just proving that he's wrong. He said a lot of things that
are wrong, whilst looking smug and trying to seem smart and also
just mostly because it just makes him mad. He wouldn't have spoken
about it three times in the span of two days if it didn't make
him mad. That's true. Okay, there we go. I'm trying to nestle
this in. Good. If there's anything in this video you don't like,
I guess you can skip it through it. But yeah, like he's not a
sociopath like Destiny is. I'm a sociopath. Just like give me
one DM. What is the most sociopathic? I don't know how much long
the science. He He knows what the next thing is there. And I'll
just pull it up one more time. In case you guys weren't here
before, I'll just pull it up one more time. Okay, one more time.
This is where the VOD cuts. I wonder why Destiny would cut off
here without actually waiting to see what DM sociopath just like
give me one DM. What? What is the most sociopathic? What? Because
of the DOS kid again. Do we just have to pull like I literally
pulled the four screenshots up from the Anna thing. give me one
that for you sometime, but for now, look, look, we pulled the
DM. Immediately, we could pull the DM of him totally manipulating
somebody who has a like a mental illness where they're like spiraling,
right? And he's exploiting them. And why would that be why would
that be bad? Okay, why would that be bad when she's like when
she's saying, "Hey, I really want you to correct this opinion
that I'm a stalker and you you can do that, right?" And he's
like, "Yeah, I'll fix it sometime, but let's just keep for now."
Okay. For now, let's just keep and okay, just to drive it home
all the way, there's just clips on clips on clips. I should remember
what the name of this video was so I don't have to go back to
my history to find it. But does Destiny think this is bad? Yeah,
he thinks it's bad. Let me find the video
from yesterday. Where is it? Where is it? Where? Hold on. There's
I have it from here yesterday. I have it here from yesterday.
Just wait. I never remember which one it is. Not this one. This
one
is bad. But people Yes, you're right. But people don't always
know what informed consent. And
but I wouldn't say the point is bad wrong because children can't
consent. Okay, great. But do you think that mentally ill women
who are caught in feedback loops are able to consent? No, they're
not. That's why I would say it's probably immoral to have with
mentally ill people. But I wouldn't say the point is bad. That's
like uh that's like his opinion, right? I don't have that opinion.
That's like his opinion, right? That's like his opinion. And
and he's saying, "Oh, yeah. Yeah. Listen, I'm I'm going to keep
rubbing your feet." Okay.
Wait.
So, we're having actual texts. No, she didn't leak her because
she couldn't leak her because Destiny threatened that if she
leaked her with him, he would post her nudes. And he's clearly
a psychopath, right? So, she didn't leak her. No. But you could
almost say this is you could almost certainly say this is Destiny
has a massive foot fetish.
No doubt, right? No doubt. Wait,
they were at this time. Do you guys not remember where he said
he would leak her nudes if she leaked his Do we not understand
that? Oh no, there's a lot of DJers. Okay. Unlucky.
Unlucky. Do I have to pull the the
about him licking [__] off of a girl's feet? Do I
have to pull that that text chain for you? Do I have to pull
that text chain for you guys to prove that he's a foot fetish
or are we good here? I don't want to have to pull the text the
with Rose where he talks about licking [__] off of
a girl's feet. Okay, disgusting.
Anyway,
what's next? I think that's it. I think we finally we got there.
We got all the way through it. We did it, Kelly. We got 3 hours
and 45 minutes of content and we still have the Dan versus Dorio
recap from earlier today.
Awesome. Awesome. Awesome.
OMFG, he's pro. I dude, OMFG, he's pro. This is probably the
last time I'm going to explain what's annoying about your posts,
right? I laid out a few facts in a row. Okay. Destiny says it's
weird to to have with mentally women who are in feedback loops.
That's spiraling. Anavore was in a feedback loop, right? He used
that feedback loop to maintain control over her. Okay. To to
continue conversations. Oh, I'll fix it, but let's just keep
having like a conversation instead. Right. Right. He's doing
these things. He says they're bad. And then somebody says, "Well,
I don't know if like rubbing her feet is necess necessarily."
And I say, "Oh, no. It is because he is a disgusting foot frog."
So, why is it relevant? What fetishes he has?
It's pretty obvious from the set of statements why it's why it's
relevant to what I'm talking about. So, if you continue to be
a 60 IQ person, a 60 IQ goldfish, very intelligent goldfish,
by the way, okay? If you continue to do that and have no object
permanence in my chat, I will time you out because it is very
annoying to have to correct you and explain why I'm actually
saying the things I'm saying. If you can't follow the conversation,
stop typing. Thank you. Have a good day.
Haw.